the level of entitlement seems to stack
up M the longer they have waited for
someone to pop the question do you think
men shouldn't open doors I think they
absolutely should open doors 100% no I
was going to say so you feel like women
are feel more entitled after to any fire
yeah because they haven't got what they
were promised like like pear just said
there's this level of they've been
promised they've been sold this dream
their whole life since they were a young
girl like you're a princess you're going
to find your prince charming this is
going to happen and it hasn't happened
yet hasn't happened yet hasn't happened
yet that expectation is building up and
up and up and that builds that
entitlement along with it